c
ok ok donc je le repas avec pas dans mon
oncle de repas quelle heure il est
illégal non regarde partout voilà
j'aurais pas dû regarder
bon allez on se concentre on se calme et
on pense à un truc cool quand quelque
chose d'apaisant un beau paysage c'est à
dire elle est quand même bonne la
stagiaire non mais ça se dit pas certain
en même temps surtout personnes nanties
ok je suis seul avec elle au bureau
salut moi c'est ça thomas enchanté moi
c'est humain sinon on baisse directe et
pourquoi je pense à ça c'était bien
comme situation c'était calme on
apprenait à faire connaissance
c'est le frigo combattants on s'en fout
de ça non ce qu'il faut c'est se
concentrer sur une situation romantique
qu'est ce qu'il fout là cette affiche
mais c'est pas celle que j'ai vu hier
chez le coiffeur mais c'est pas le
moment de penser à ça ça devait être
pour du savon tétouan ou du shampoing
aller 1 1 on arrête on se calme et on
pense à la stagiaire et on la baise la
gueule du coup ça fait longtemps que tu
travailles ici ouais tiens lui commencé
comme toi stagiaire au début et puis le
nul imaginez la réaction des gens at on
affaire non mais dis que tu es vraiment
utile plus rien tu me laisses tranquille
au caire ah ouais je vois en fait t'es
amoureux
quoi quoi quoi mais n'importe quoi je
suis pas amoureux parent attendant tu
arrives pas à penser à autre chose en
attendant je n'arrive pas à dormir parce
que tu veux pas la boucle est quoi
tentant le coeur qui bat vachement vite
c'est la preuve que tu es amoureux du
grand large des côtes c'est parce qu'il
reste deux heures à dormir et ben tu la
fermes alors allez calme at one ses
résidents c'est ma faute je voulais te
dire un truc mais c'est un peu spécial
je t'écoute voilà chantepie d'où
s'étaient shampooing doux la marque
change we do tu frottes samus et c'est
show with où tu crois que ça mousse
existe toujours s'amuser c'est touchant
rock
la merde que je vais te faire bouffer si
tu la fermes marche morgen moi même ça
n'a aucun sens c'est tout faux pas tais
toi tais toi et moi madame tu crois que
tu vas t'en dormir en pensant et ben
comme c'est mignon fut pas je veux
dormir si tu la fermes alors je vais te
trouver et un ferme et haga où tu
comptes me trouver comment ma conscience
à partir j'imagine où je vais alors trop
voir ses gardes pour toi parce que plus
d'efforts pour nous il te reste combien
de temps à dormir là en se marrant quand
je m'énerve je monte dans les aigus ya
trois enterrements te croyais rêver
est-ce que j'ai fermé la porte et le
circuit
aux honduriens tue pas trouvé c'est quoi
j'en ai vraiment marre d'entendre ses
patins voix c'est ma voie ou une autre
voie où je m'avance dans la pièce était
face c'est une situation que j'avais
jamais vécu soit tu te tais maintenant
ils menacent leur meilleure soirée de
fête est par la force
nuance nous sommes en train de dire et
alors qu'est ce que tu attends pour me
faire taire tu as des doutes mais
attention tu as intérêt à rester
concentré c'est un beau matin ce que
j'espère mais n'a pas montré que j'ai
pensé à fermer alors choisi quoique on
est vieux on s'habille comme des vieux
alors
je suis me reste combien de temps à
dormir dehors des médias non mais c'est
pas sûr qu'à travers
chants ville où tu flottes samus et
c'est jean louis d'où tu prouves samus
et c'est le genre we do not sa série 2 0
jean boudou les champs par les champions
elle est sûre donne mais comme je suis
net tu me rappelles
et toi tu es dans la musique c'est ça
ouais j'avais un petit groupe de musique
avec des copains